quinze jours vous voulez apprendre à
séduire des filles et à pécho un maximum
en soirée cette vidéo est faite pour
vous tout d'abord commencer par vous
abonner à la chaîne jeu squeeze ceci
n'est pas une arnaque
nous amis j'ai reçu un mail qui a attiré
mon attention c'est josh séduction qui
m'a informé de ses créations il a créé
deux applications qui s'appelle coup de
séduction et envoyer des sms de
séduction qui sont des applications
probablement destinés à des gens un peu
plus vieux que nous ok à des gens qui
ont 60 ans et non pas 20 mai d'après ses
dires à la fin de cette vidéo ne sont
capables de séduire des femmes en toute
circonstance de manière efficace et de
manière sûre lui jamais vous vous
retrouverez dans un moment de gêne face
à une femme ça n'arrivera plus je suis
sur l'application ça va se passer en
trois étapes d'un conseil moi tu
retrouveras tous les conseils officiel
écrit par nous d'un motive moi je serai
là porte à porte et de l'énergie au
moment où tu en auras besoin d'en
évaluer moi je pourrais voir site au
niveau théorique est suffisant avant de
te lancer dans la pratique première
étape franchie mois apprend moi je veux
savoir séduire il peut te conseiller
pour séduire en journée et en soirée
pour séduire un mec pour séduire par
messages vont séduire sur internet ont
rendez vous en coupe quoi c'est pas cool
du tout ça scandaleux
ok en journée les bases mais l'accès y
faire complice génial le lieu qui peut
aborder dans la rue dans un magasin dans
un parc un jardin public un centre
commercial à la plage mais c'est du
harcèlement de rue ça apparemment
d'après certaines femmes enfin attention
attention elles n'ont pas forcément
envie d'être dérangé dans la rue deux
cas difficiles si la fillette avec un
groupe d'amis ils ont analysé des femmes
sigle officiel un endroit dit à pression
sociale par exemple dans le bus
fictivement on n'est pas l'abri d'une
petite descente du coude dans les boules
un bon autres conseils de bon sens mais
ça ne fait pas de mal de le rappeler
j'adore qu'on évite les rues sont nés et
roi de la nuit la fille aura tendance à
prendre peur plus facilement
j'espère que parmi vous personne n'a
tenté séduire une fille dans une rue
étroite et sombre la nuit vraiment ne te
mets pas trop de barrières en soit tous
les lieux sont possibles avec
d'orthographe
l'état d'esprit attention à ce que
d'allemagne c'est à palma et la fille
valentine c'est comme les chevaux
étaient stressés le sang et vient de
comparer les femmes aux chevaux allez à
bientôt fin de carrière soit de bonne
humeur c'est contagieux
la personne à qui tu parles le sera
aussi ne prend pas trop au sérieux
amuse-toi de chaque situation mec je
suis désolé de dire bière faut faire
attention quand même trois comme quoi
aujourd'hui la selafa tu fais pour des
biens ont attaqué leurs homologues
rennais vient mourir étouffés dans les
marches être d'aller voir à ces noms
c'est leur reste humble même si tu
possèdes des biens matériels n'essaie
pas de le montrer à tout prix par
exemple si tu as un yacht mentionne
simplement un petit bateau ainsi tu
gagnes l'effet de surprise mais en plus
tu as l'air de quelqu'un d'humble
dallaire d'un gros fils de [ __ ] wabush
pas réussi à trouver mieux mais bon ce
sera un cadeau de plus mineures des
réactions et émotions ne pas rire aux
éclats pour quelque chose de moyennement
marron ne pas être excessivement triste
pour quelque chose de banal ne soit pas
squeeze ok on passe à l'énergie avant de
commencer si tu n'es pas au top de ton
énergie utilisent des méthodes
ci-dessous premier mort toi les
meilleurs moments vécus dans ta vie
quand je suis passé diamant sur roach
exerce sautoir notamment saluant des
inconnus en souriant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu es un peu endormi cours quelques
instants de 30 secondes et une minute
cela te réveilleras tu vas surtout pu et
on arrive à tous rendez-vous monga fait
pas sa passion au langage du corps
anne sommes confiants n'hésite pas à
prendre de la place match breeding
arrêter quand tu expliques quelque chose
utilisent des mouvements la dernière
fois le mec il arrive lâche du québec ne
fait aucun geste brusque vous pourriez
blessée la femme vraiment apprend à être
à l'aise avec tes mains ce qu'un jour
quelqu'un vous a dit j'ai un problème
dans la vie je suis mal à l'aise avec
mes mains s'il ya bien quelque chose
avec lequel tu n'es pas mal à l'aise
c'est à main surtout coach une bonne
grosse partie de ping pong
merci à tous les amis il est temps
d'apprendre à gérer le contact visuel
dès l'instant où tu te trouves en face
de votre interlocuteur regard son visage
et surtout pas sa poitrine soutient son
regard ce tu n'y arrives pas tu peux
regarder autour de ses yeux le plus
proche possible de ses pupilles
[Musique]
c'est dérangeant c'est dérangeant ne le
fait pas tu peut par exemple utiliser la
technique des 3 zones regard l'oeil
droit le gauche la bouche le décolleté
non tous ses conseils me mettre
profondément mal à l'aise tous
acquiescent en faisant oui d'un
mouvement de la tête pour lui faire
comprendre que tu l'écoutés que tu es
d'accord ça il ya des gens des fois
qu'ils font ça quand je leur parle ça
m'énerve du ragondin truc un peu long
parce que tu as mal jaugé la durée de la
blague par rapport à la chute ces
techniques un truc pendant 20 secondes
et que la chute est nul ça le fait pas
moi je suis un pro pour faire ça au
québec à leur foi jean maxence major au
monoprix dit qu on arrive à la caisse
caissière brune et où elle rien maxence
et en fait c'était sa soeur tu veux
vivre tu fais une grosse claque dans la
gueule de merde
attention certains qui ne le fait jamais
vraiment craqué devant tous les autres
abonnés bon je rappelle qu'il est
toujours en train d'apprendre comment
faire pour ensuite le mettre en pratique
juste après votre nez mais à 12 heures
l'attitude des patois calmement évite de
faire des gestes brusques
mais quand il ya vraiment elle guide
genre légende 6e ronde et [ __ ] des
psychopathes qu'en jargon cher mais
comment se déplacer il faisait les
phrases d' approche directe suffit pas
on vous dans la rue elle est très très
jolie vous voulez lui parler qu'est ce
que vous dites ça lui en fait quand je
t'ai vu j'ai envie de te parler tu as
l'air super sympa ça dérange si je
marche avec toi cinq minutes c'est pour
te draguer tu veux parler de quoi
je suis la fille j'appelle la police
tout du mec j'ai envie de tester des
techniques de la rue pour montrer à quel
point ça ne peut pas marcher
les amis nous avons avalé les conseils
de ces gens maintenant il faut se
motiver pour aller séduire alors on va
aller dans motive mois mais motivant en
fait c'est juste une synthèse de ce
qu'on aime voir l'isoler mois du groupe
et de ses amis elle ne subira plus de
pression sociale ne sera vraiment
elle-même ce moment est le meilleur pour
récupérer son numéro voir l'embrasser
viens je vais te montrer un truc là-bas
suis moi je te présenter un ami vient va
prendre l'air ça fait longtemps que
prévu les étoiles c'est bon vous savez
maintenant comment séduire une fille
comment commencé à lui parler comment
l'aborder sont la déranger comment
maintenir son attention quand on lui
parle comment prendre ses coordonnées
pour la revoir comment l'isoler en
soirée encore plus dû casser les
couilles c'est parti avant de commencer
une session draguant journée tu ne suis
pas motivé et tuner suis pas parler
français tu te sens mal à l'aise tu n'as
pas d'énergie que dois tu faire je dois
quand même aborder même si je me sens
mal à l'aise je dois sortir du mois pour
changer d idée je dois rien faire et
rester chez moi il faut sortir et saluer
les gens en souriant on l'a vu tout à
l'heure pour toi la façon de parler à
une fille c'est peu importe qui tu as
des couilles que lentement avec une voix
grave
tulle a ajouté sur facebook ton premier
message sera cache le propose direct
inverse mon premier message pourquoi la
femme n'écrira pas pour une fois pour
une fois mais ferme là à deux minutes
soit je la joue classique en la saluant
soit je tente une blague avec les infos
récupérées sur son profil et oui mon ami
je suis prêt à séduire je crois bien à
tanger en vie qui me valut pour en
soirée est ce que je pourrais séduire en
soirée tu dois les niçois rémy tu es
nerveux que vas tu faire pour te
décontracté je vais boire d'alcool et
fument une cigarette je vais regarder
sur internet des techniques de
méditation et relaxation
c'est la bonne réponse mec vraiment la
bonne réponse c'est un vrai mec faut
être complètement stressée du cul pour
en arriver là vandales en soirée quand
même c'est foutu à une heure a attendu
ne sait pas quoi faire en attendant mais
tu as trois idées je vais faire une
sieste je vais réviser la séduction et
développement personnel en général je
vais commencer à boire un verre et fumer
une clope pour mettre bien mais je vais
réviser les amis c'est officiel nous
pouvons séduit à en journée et en soirée
le matin c'est mort bonjour c'est paul
avez-vous pensé à travailler cinq
minutes de séduction aujourd'hui
laisse-moi paulès bois et laisse les
fans troqué les amis c'est la fin de
cette première application attention
j'ai un petit bonus pour vous bien sûr
quelque chose qui va vous aider mais dès
ce soir envoyé des sms de séduction
c'est la deuxième application de pierre
situé dans une situation de panique et
que tu es dans l'une des situations
présentes ici tu vas pouvoir s'en sortir
grâce à un sms déjà écrit bonjour c'est
sofia tu pensais envoyé des messages au
fait qu'il plaise mais laisse moi tu as
des bus sur une fille ça fait
vingt-quatre heures qu'elle t'a pas
envoyé de message tu vas dans la
catégorie elle ne répond pas voici une
liste de sms préfet par exemple je pense
souvent du temps pour écrire un message
gentille et toi tu ignores mes efforts
bon on n'en voyez surtout pas celui-là à
génial tu parles à des mecs pour perdre
ton temps facile elle dit qu'elle a un
copain gros problème ok tant pis pour
toi salut ça va passer ça passe à
ramallah filles qu'elles coupent le mois
stable du monde nommé ciel un copain
partait fermé la porte et appuyer sur ce
jeu est choisie est basé le temps c'est
fini la drague air explicitement il est
11 heures 11 leur parfaite pour faire un
voeu moi je te veux
ce film serait tellement mieux si tu le
regardes et dans mes bras ok lover on a
un problème je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser à toi tu as mais paul devient la
toile ou fait des massages mon gars tu
nous mets tous bien j'aime tes yeux mais
je préfère les miens car sans eux je ne
peux pas voir les tient à temps ce qui a
comme une catégorie message profond il
te faudra deux secondes pour lire que tu
compte beaucoup pour moi et toute une
vie pour te le prouver
est ce que je pouvais en savoir un peu
plus sur toi tu as pas confondu tous je
suis un mec bien je ne bois pas je ne
fume pas je prends soin de moi excuses
nous un toi qui est si parfait le
déteste le mexique ce message ok
messages de bonnes nuits je sois de
t'endormir dans le coton doux de la nuit
et de te réveiller dans la douceur du
miel du matin bonne nuit sache que je
vais rêvé de toi ce soir et ce jusqu'à
demain et même jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
mais qui fait un référendum je propose
de renommer cette appli canard lord les
avait sa fin cette vidéo si vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aller mais
comme d'habitude la bonne nouvelle c'est
que maintenant on est tous capable de
séduire des femmes ou de leur faire
extrêmement peur et de finir au
commissariat je sais pas je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui ont des facilités pour
aller parler aux inconnus et d'autres en
ont beaucoup moins et si ça peut aider
des gens tant mieux mais dans mon cas ya
plein de trucs qui ont fait marrer dans
ce qu'il dit même s'il ya plein de
choses qui sont vraies en réalité dans
le comportement avoir la gestuelle la
tenue le machin le truc en fait ça
s'appelle de la pnl quand l'enfant et je
parle pas des groupes taper nlc la
programmation neuro linguistique c'est
pas marqué sur un écran c'est faux et
c'est des modèles et des techniques
destinées à faciliter la communication
entre des gens et il a dit des choses
dans son appli c'est de la pnl bon bien
on remercie au nom de tous les abonnés
grâce à toi on sera un as en soirée et
en journée bravo pour tes applis
puisqu'elle est mon bien fait marrer et
je pense qu'elles aideront des gens donc
c'est cool tu dois pécho un maximum de
femmes de 50 ans par contre sinon ça ça
peut pas marcher allez vous dis à
bientôt de marchiennes de personnes
regardent et se bat pour séduire des
femmes ce sport
[Musique]